(swooshing)
(electronic tones)
- We have another advocate,
a legal advocate, Kara Chien,
who is our next speaker, and Miss Chien,
if you'll come to the podium.
Kara is the managing attorney
for the Mental Health Unit
of the Public Defender's
Office of San Francisco,
so we are delighted to
have her for the first time
at our podium, and I know
you're going to be talking about
a lot of topics, mental
health issues, legal defense,
and developmental
disabilities, and bullying,
and all sorts of things,
so educate us, thank you.
- Thank you, and Jeff says hi.
- Thank you.
- Good morning, thank you for having me.
I love to attend medical
conference, even though
I'm not a doctor, but I
grew up with 12 doctors.
My grandparents, my parents,
my uncles and aunts,
and each time I attend
(clearing throat) conference,
I always feel very
hopeful, warm and fuzzy,
because I get to learn all the innovative
treatment techniques, best practices.
It's very inspiring, but when
I attend legal conference,
it's a little bit, (laughing)
(audience laughing)
I hate to say it, cold,
hard, impersonal sometimes,
and we talk about justice, deterrents,
lack of confidentiality,
and really whether you are
a defendant, an offender, or a victim.
It really puts the person in
a very traumatic position,
where at the end of that legal experience,
it's really hard to make them
go back to the status quo.
I'm gonna share what I know
because that's what I do
for a living, I represent
clients with mental disorders,
which is the psychiatric...
Psychiatric diagnosis, or the clients
with developmental disabilities,
and I also represent
clients who are in the criminal court
who are found not
competent to stand trial,
who may or may not have
developmental disabilities.
So, I'm gonna go in and we're gonna
talk about, first of all, bullying.
Now, I would like to
have one of the audience.
Laura, are you here?
Laura, can you read the
definition of bullying for me?
Let me see, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Not sure how to do this.
Hello?
- Okay.
- [Laura] Bullying,
any severe or pervasive
physical or verbal acts or conduct,
including electronic communications
committed by a pupil,
or pupils, that has, or can be,
reasonably predicted to have
the effect of one or
more of the following:
reasonable fear of harm
to a person or property,
substantially detrimental effect
on physical or mental health,
substantial interference
with academic performance,
with the ability to
participate in or benefit
from school services,
activities, or privileges.
- Thank you, Laura.
- You're welcome.
- (clapping) Give her a hand.
(audience applauding)
For a non-lawyer, you're
doing a great job,
so it's a mouthful, just
bullying, you bully someone.
Somebody got upset as a result
of just the act of bullying,
the bullying act, that's it,
but this is the definition,
and we have to break it down.
I share with you because this is codified
in the California Education
Code, and also, this is posted
in San Francisco Unified School District.
So, I saw some of the
attendees' name cards.
I know you're not from California,
or may be from another county,
so welcome to San Francisco.
So, it's always a good idea
to go to your local area
to look up your unified school district,
what are their policies,
what are their rules,
what are their definitions?
So, even in California,
it's very county specific.
So, in San Francisco, if
you go on their website,
they will define different
types of bullying,
and I don't see it in
Alameda County website.
In San Francisco, they
mention cyberbullying,
which is very, we read
about it all the time,
Facebook, through social
media, of text, an image,
a sound or a video, that
counts cyberbullying,
if that triggers upset on
the person who's receiving
the message, and the verbal
bullying, that's very obvious.
Physical bullying, it's
act of fighting or hitting.
Social or relational bullying,
and that's kind of like
people have a clique and
try to be exclusionary,
excluding someone into that social group.
That act is also considered bullying.
Non-verbal bullying is a
gesture, staring, stalking,
and destruction of property,
so it's not a verbal,
not a physical, but it's
something that kind of latent.
It's kind of difficult to detect.
The last one is indirect bullying.
It's intimidating or
peer pressure on someone
to cause harm to a third party,
so it's indirect bullying.
If my child goes to school
and someone bullies her.
She comes home really
upset, and this child
cut in front of me, we were
standing in the cafeteria.
Is that bullying?
Well, that's a rude behavior,
so we need to sort of
pay attention when we get the message,
when we want to make that
report of that incident,
we need to think about it,
and organize our facts.
So, if it was just one isolative incident,
if the incident is done
unintentionally to cause someone
else to be upset, such
as saying oh I'm great
and you're not smart
'cause I got an A today.
So, that may not be constituted bullying.
That may be just somebody
being inconsiderate.
So, what we look for is those
conduct that is a pattern.
Yesterday he said this, today he did this,
and in the afternoon
he said the same thing.
So, when you make your
reporting, then people will
pay attention, not just one
isolative incident, so that's--
- Speak a little more in
here so the overflow room
can hear you, thank you so much.
- Sorry. (laughing)
- No problem.
(audience laughing)
- Alright.
- Was that bullying?
- (laughing) No!
That was a very helpful hint.
(laughing with audience)
See, that's, so we need
to, it's really hard
when it's my child and
when it's the victim.
So, when we go to the
school board, when we go
to the teacher, we make the
reporting, write it down.
Documentation is very
important, and especially
clients, or patients, or your
loved one, who is non-verbal,
and who is constantly being picked on,
someone who's really
bad, and there's nobody
to defend this child, and
this child cannot express
how she feels, but you
know that she's upset.
You know her daily routine has changed.
My daughter studies
cognitive behavioral science,
and she wants to use our therapy to help
with trauma victims, so
having a piece of paper,
say draw what happened,
tell me how you feel,
that's important, or if we're very lucky,
we ask questions around our
child's friends, peer provider,
see if there's a third party
witness who saw the incident.
That will be very
powerful, so documentation,
searching for third party witness,
and then make your report,
and in San Francisco,
once you make your
report, they have two days
to ask you to file a complaint,
and they will investigate,
and they will do a
resolution of the complaint,
and that, sometimes, in San
Francisco, it's counseling,
therapy, behavioral
modification of the wrongdoer.
For severe and pervasive
bullying that triggers
a lot of harm, then that
student may face expulsion,
or suspension, and if that
comes, if your loved one
is the offender, you can contact
the San Francisco Public Defender's Office
or your local public defender's office.
They may have a juvenile
unit, and the juvenile unit,
they have an educational
expert who goes to the school,
or maybe advise the family how to do
these administrative hearings
so you can prevent your child
to reduce from expulsion to a suspension.
Maybe a suspension to something
a little bit more be not
because if my child has special needs,
I need to let them know,
and they should not penalize
like a child who is
without the special needs.
So, they need to take
those mitigating factors
into consideration, so
that's very important.
And, if there is no
criminal code that says
if you commit a bullying act,
you're gonna be prosecuted.
So, the act of bullying,
depending on how it's done,
for example, I'm gonna kill you,
I'm threatening to kill you,
or actually hit somebody.
If it's serious enough,
if there's a physical,
like bite mark, or if there is,
like cutting that requires suturing,
then the report will
escalate to be San Francisco
Police Department, or to
the local police department
for an incident report,
and they can file charges,
excuse me, against the
individual who committed the act.
So, it could be an assault,
battery, or terrorist threat,
or hate crime, so if that does happen,
if your loved one, or your
patient, or your client is a
(clearing throat) victim,
then it's best to contact
a local district attorney's
office to make sure that
(item dropping loudly)
the, that's okay,
the individual gets support
from the, oh thank you,
I'm sorry, thank you.
- Mm-hmm.
- Make sure the individual
gets support from the
victim services and advocacy unit.
So, when I contact their office and I say
what kind of services you can offer?
Well, we will pay for the
mental health counseling,
we will pay for relocation,
we will pay for, sometimes,
vicarious victims, the family
members are also traumatized,
so they will give support.
For example, if the regional
center, through Medical,
pays for the counseling, but
if you have to pay anything
out of pocket, you can
submit the bill and say
please reimburse me, and
also for victims if they are
uncomfortable testifying in a courtroom,
they have therapy dog
to assist the victim,
to feel more comfortable
so they can testify,
just to calm down their
nerves a little bit.
So, that's from a victim perspective.
If the victim,
unfortunately, is non-verbal
or have a lot of difficulty
expressing his or herself,
it's very important to
contact the provider
and let the district attorney's
office is the victim service
case worker, that probably
he or she needs trauma
inform approach to help
her through the case
during litigation, and use
trauma specific intervention
so the victim will not
be impacted, and scared,
and feel stress during
the pendency of the case.
In the unfortunate event, if
the person is being charged
for a crime as a result of bullying
or other serious criminal
offense, please don't be afraid,
and it's always, just take a deep breath.
How many of us, in our car,
we have an emergency kit?
Can you raise your hand?
Yes, so if your child, your
client, or your patient
has developmental disabilities,
it's very important
to have a fact sheet,
the name, the provider,
the case worker, medication,
what are the triggers,
what are the things that
calm him or her down,
what are the things
that this person needs?
And if, in the unfortunate
event, my client,
at the time of the arrest,
it's very important
for the family to come
forward and fax that letter
to the attorney, or fax
the letter to the people
who are in charge of the
investigation of the case.
And, in San Francisco, we
have two pilot projects.
One is called Law Enforcement
Assisted Diversion.
So, let's say the case,
it's being reported
to the school district,
it's pretty serious,
but this is the first time.
So, when the police come to the school
and gather information and they say, well,
it's a very low level criminal
activity, it's upsetting,
but we're gonna give this person a chance.
They will not be booked,
and they will be diverted
in the community to do
therapy, counseling,
or community service work,
and after a period of time,
and there is no recidivism,
no re-offending,
then they will let this case go,
so that's one of the legal remedies.
The second one, it's called
Pre-arraignment Release Unit,
PRU, it started last October,
and when people are booked
in the county jail,
public defender's office,
we have two attorneys
and one investigator,
we will interview the client,
review the discoveries.
When we say discoveries, police report,
chronology investigation, as
much as we can get within hours
of their booking, we try to
take photos if our clients
are being beaten, so we'll
preserve the evidence,
and then we will try to
get the clients released
before their court date, so
shorten their stay in custody,
and that will definitely really
help to not have our clients
with special needs being
traumatized in such
a horrific setting, and if the
person does not get released,
sometimes maybe the charges are serious,
or maybe the victim's family
are pressuring prosecution.
We also have a bail unit
that will file bail motions
to try to reduce the bail.
A judge should not set
a bail that is so high
somebody could not afford
it, so it is a big thing
in California right
now, it's a bail reform,
so that would help the client to post bail
if it's affordable so
they can litigate the case
and out of custody, and
allow the client to reconnect
with the provider, get
treatment, get counseling
while the case is pending, so that's,
it's very important because
it reduces the stress
of the clients, and also
it helps the attorney
to connect with the
client's support circle
so we can figure out a defense.
If the case goes to court,
and if we have gathered
enough information,
and convinced the judge
to allow the client to,
what we call diversion,
it's kinda similar to the Law Enforcement
Assisted Diversion, but
this is already booking,
and formal complaint has been
filed, and allow the client
to do therapy, to do community
service work, and also
our San Francisco District
Attorney likes to do
restorative justice, so
maybe everybody sit down,
the offender apologizes to the victim,
and the victim accepts the
apology, or if they destroy
some property, they
will repay the property,
and afterwards, everybody shakes hands
and have a nice closure, and
the case will be dismissed.
So sometimes, that kind
of outcome could happen,
but if the case is so serious
and it's not going anywhere,
it's not resolving right
away with dismissal,
San Francisco has collaborative courts.
People with mental illness,
psychiatric mental illness,
or developmental disabilities,
or sometimes people
who are veterans, who have a
history of substance abuse,
we have different courts.
We have drug court, veteran's court,
behavioral health court, misdemeanor
behavioral health court,
and also youth court,
transitional youth age court.
It depends on the offense and
their eligibility criteria.
Basically, we try to use the
judge's black robe effect
to encourage compliance with treatment,
and hopefully after a period
of time, when the client
demonstrates ability to
engage, and there are no
re-offending incidents that
they would dismiss the case,
or they will reduce from
a felony to a misdemeanor,
or they will reduce the
time of being on probation,
so the client can become reintegrated back
to the community without having to worry,
I have this criminal case hanging around.
Sometimes, at this stage, a
lot of family members call me.
Anxious mom, loving sisters,
or loving father or brother.
I wanna know what's going on with my son.
What's happening with the case?
And I said, I can't talk
to you, I don't have
a release of information. (laughing)
If it's a minor, then I
can talk to the parents,
but if it's an adult, it's difficult.
So, how do we get at least
our foot into the door?
How do we at least get
to share information?
Remember, I mentioned the
fact sheet, so you can always
send me a fact sheet, you
can always talk to me.
I don't wanna be rude, but I
won't be able to talk to you
and discuss the case in
detail, but there is a way.
I think it's good to have
something to allow you
to have a seat at the table,
and that will be my suggestion
is the limited probate conservatorship.
So what a limited probate
conservatorship does in California
is to give a responsible person, generally
it's a family member, as
a limited conservator,
certain rights to care for another adult
who has a developmental
disability, and who is eligible?
I believe that the regional
center can make the assessment,
and you use the assessment
to file the paperwork.
You don't need a lawyer, you
can go to the help center
in the courthouse to try to
get the form and fill it out.
The powers of the limited
conservator is quite extensive.
You can look at the confidential paper
of the adult's confidential paper.
You can decide where the adult lives.
You can give or withhold
consent for most of
the medical treatments,
and you can make decisions
about the adult's education
and vocational training.
You can even make decision
whether or not to place the adult
in a state hospital, a
developmental center for treatment,
and give and withhold consent
to the adult's marriage.
That's (laughing), and it's
a little bit difficult.
I think the law kinda said that
if the adult with disability
is in danger in a relationship,
then the limited conservator can step in.
So, it has a lot of power,
but I have to tell you,
in San Francisco, I checked
with the public guardian,
we don't have limited
probate conservatorship.
We use general probate conservatorship
to give the conservator
that power, yes, yes?
(woman murmuring)
It's not mental health.
Mental health conservatorship is under
the Lanterman-Petris-Short
Act, which is not covered
on today's topic, but I can
talk about a story at the end.
I'll share with you how
to transition somebody
from mental health to
developmental, but this only
for an adult with
developmental disability,
but in San Francisco, I have,
although that's not the area
of my practice, but I do know that adults
with developmental disability,
they have a conservator,
and as a general probate conservatorship.
It's not a mental health conservatorship.
Thank you for the clarification.
So, with that piece of
paper from the court,
certainly would allow the
public defender to talk to you,
or the defense attorney to talk to you.
The limited public conservator
could get compensation
from the state of the conservatee.
You will be under supervision
for the first year.
Someone from the court
will review the case,
and then they will review
once every two years,
and the liabilities is only
if the limited conservator
is negligent, like embezzling money,
doing something that's inappropriate,
and you really don't
need legal representation
to file the paper, so that's
a good tool, at least,
to get you, legitimize your
ability to talk to someone
and be helpful in the process.
If the case kind of comes in, the client,
the adult with developmental
disability is unable
to understand the criminal
proceeding and is not able
to take advantage of the
resolution that I mentioned before,
the possibility of
diversion, getting dismissed,
getting them out of jail, and figure out
what the legal remedies
while they're out of custody.
Sometimes, I even have a client who has
two misdemeanor cases in San Francisco,
one in another county, actually, was found
not competent to stand trial.
He is working with a regional center
in the state of California,
and so what constitutes
incompetent to stand trial is
the inability to understand
the nature and purpose of
the criminal proceedings
pending against him or her,
understand his or her own status
and condition in the criminal proceedings,
and assist, in a rational
manner, his or her attorney
in representing his or her case.
So, usually when the doubt is raised,
the judge will suspend
the criminal proceedings
against the client, and
what would happen is that,
the client willing not be
prosecute, and will be asked
to be examined by a court
appointed alienist expert.
So, if I know my client,
which is the fact sheet,
it's helpful that I know my client has
developmental disability, I
will try to ask the court,
we would need to get an
expert that's in that field
of specialty so the assessment
will be more accurate,
will be more helpful, and what
the alienist will look at is
full capacities, factual
understanding of the proceeding,
rational understanding of the proceeding,
ability to consult with attorney
with reasonable degree of
rational understanding,
and ability to assist counsel
in preparing a defense.
Those are pretty daunting tasks.
Even my clients without special needs
still get very stressed, distressed,
and we have to hold their hands.
They also look at decisional capacity,
which, whether to put on a defense,
raise one or more affirmative defenses.
Affirmative defense is like when,
the reason I hit somebody is
because I'm protecting my life.
That's affirmative defense.
Waiving the right to a
jury trial, to decide
whether or not a judge will
be a better trier of facts,
will be just determining the
facts, or to have 12 people
that never met you before
and come and make a decision
about your fate, so to speak.
Whether or not to take
the stand as a witness,
is my client able to take the pressure?
Waive the privilege
against self-incrimination,
giving statements, decline
to confront witnesses.
So, in cases where the
defendant is non-verbal,
or when the victim is non-verbal,
the right to confront
witnesses is a big part.
That's why if neither party could do this,
they have to suspend
a criminal proceeding.
It's a violation of
their due process rights
if you continue to prosecute
someone who's not able
to defend him or herself,
and in this type of situation
that I mentioned, one of my clients has
two misdemeanor cases
in San Francisco County,
one in another county, we were
able to convince the judge
not to remand him in
custody, and allow him to do
the program in the community,
and we did a lot of work.
We map his schedule throughout the week,
make sure that he has
supervision throughout the week,
and there are caseworkers following him,
and he comes to court,
maybe once every two months,
and within six months or so,
if he completed his treatment,
completed his treatment plan,
he did not pick up a case,
those cases would be dismissed.
So, it's doable, but it
takes time, and that's why
I always go back to that fact sheet.
It's very, very important.
It would not be complete for talking about
mental health issues and legal defense for
developmentally disabled
individuals without mention,
which I don't like to talk about,
is the Welfare Institution's Code 6500.
I don't do a lot of these
cases, maybe one or two a year
in San Francisco, it's rarely filed,
and the law has changed since 2012,
so the commitment is not
lengthy and indefinite,
so there are two types after 2012.
One is based on dangerous
criteria, and that is
for someone who has committed
a crime and is not competent
to stand trial, so I
have one case, which is,
the person committed a murder 187,
so this person is committed under 6500,
and it used to be, I will
continue to follow the case
every year for extension
of the commitment,
and now it's done in Tulare County.
So, Tulare County's
Public Defender's Office
will be following that commitment.
The other one is a civil
commitment, when someone is in
acute crisis, and the
need to be committed,
and it's very rare.
It only happens when, once
in a while, our clients are
in the home and is becoming 17 and-a-half
and he needs to go to adult
facility while we're waiting.
The licensing and all the things
required is to have a 6500,
just like a placeholder until this person
is safely transitioned into a home,
and then I will make sure
the commitment is terminated.
So, it doesn't go, it used to
be every year is renewable.
Now, it's 180 days, and
then they will only give you
another 90 day, the court
will only allow to give
another 90 days extend to make sure
the transitional placement has completed,
the individual is no longer
in acute crisis mode,
and they can safely live in the community.
In closing, I just wanted to share,
I started working in the mental
health unit in the year 2000
and to me, developmental
disability was really
a foreign language to me, and in court,
we don't use intellectual
disability, we don't use
cognitive disability, or
developmental disability.
We just use one term along,
a lump, just uncompressed
for the whole thing, and
sometimes some attorney will say,
"My client has a mental health issue."
And then, it turns out it's
developmental disability.
It's not psychiatric, so if
we know, if we are providers,
take the time and explain the difference.
I think the person who
gets the information
would appreciate it 'cause
there's really, for me
who's been doing it for
a while, it's really
sounding like, okay, let's go back
and let's distinguish if
they are very different.
So, I have a client who
was born deaf and mute,
and he has an adoptive parents.
The father is a sign language interpreter,
the mother is a writer, and
he was found to be unable to
live in the community, he was
placed in Napa State Hospital.
At that time, there was a deaf unit,
people with hearing impair,
so by the year of 2006 and 7,
Napa State Hospital said,
"We no longer want to renew
"his conservatorship, I don't
care, you're gonna put him
"on the street, but we don't want him."
Because they no longer have
a deaf unit, and thank God
the adoptive parents was
very good record keeper.
They found something years
before that, like five years old,
right after he was born,
there was assessment
by the regional centers
saying that he has autism.
Ah-ha, so we said, well let's
talk to the regional center.
But, because my client
had a history of put out,
15 staff member out of commission,
nobody wants to touch him
(sighing) so it took me two years.
I bring regional center
lawyer, regional center
social worker, I bring
the mental health people,
the conservator, two
years, every other week
I want them to come to court,
so what are you gonna do for my client?
He needs a place to stay.
I know that if I'm greedy,
I ask for a whole pie,
I'm not gonna get it, so
thank God I'm Chinese,
I'm a good bargain person, so I ask--
(audience laughing)
I ask one slice of the pie
at the time, and I said look,
he's in wrist restraints
75% of the time, what can
you do as a regional center
if you cannot provide a
placement, what services
can you provide in Napa to
augment it so we can reduce
his quality of having to
be in wrist restraint,
the length of time, and to
improve his quality of life?
So, they brought into assess
person to work with him,
and then somehow miracle happened.
These two people said,
"Napa State Hospital
"is not the appropriate
placement for him."
I said, "Ah-ha, okay, so let's
look for one." (laughing)
(audience laughing)
So, every two weeks,
we come back, so have you
seen one, Sierra Vista,
this place turned him down,
that place turned him down,
then we found Porterville, said,
"I don't like Porterville."
I said, "Where is Porterville?"
So, I looked at the map, so far
away, and his adopted mother
has industrial allergies, she
can't go to certain place,
so she was like, "I can't go
there, I may have allergy."
So, we worked with the client, and finally
they got him a bed space at Porterville.
So, when he went there, I was
very scared because everybody,
I think the staff from
Porterville had to go to Napa
to learn about his sign language.
His sign language is not the
conventional sign language.
It's something he make
up, and only the people
that work with him knows
what he meant by doing
this and that, and so they
learned that and they did
really have a thoughtful transition team,
and so it helps to be persistent
and be a pain in the butt.
(laughing) So, coming to court every
other week 'til they make the report.
Finally, he went to
Porterville, and I learned that
the treatment modality
is different from Napa,
and so I really wanted
to know how he's doing
because we'd been working
with him for so many years.
So, one day I went to Porterville.
I went to the unit to visit
him, and I saw this man sitting,
his back turned towards me,
he was sitting at a table
having lunch with three other people.
He's not in restraints, wrist restraints.
He was walking around freely,
and then his staff told me,
he said, "He goes to a party.
"He even has a girlfriend,
too." (laughing)
- [Audience] Aww.
- And so, the last time I
checked with the social worker,
I believe he's living in a
boarding care in the community.
It takes a village to help
someone with special needs.
It takes compassion, it takes commitment,
and I think we can make
the impossible possible.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)